yeah you know it's it's hard to tell
until we start to see it now this is a
team that's trying to bust through that
you know brian flores i think has been a
great coach and i think he's got the
potential to become one of the best
coaches in football but that they've got
to find a way to take the next step last
year it felt like they were going to
take it they just fell short of
qualifying for that 17 field in the afc
and this year they got to get over the
top let's take a look at their
their position groups look we know where
they are at quarterback they're going to
ride with tua we think
jacoby brissette not on the field
unless
tuatanga villa was injured but at the
running back position we heard from
miles gaskin they have malcolm brown
solomon ahmed
jared dokes a rookie
what
nothing jumps out i don't know yeah it's
underwhelming it's it's it's almost
isn't this what the patriots have done
brian flores comes from new england it's
a revolving door of guys that have a
role and there isn't that stud
every down tail back on the roster
exactly right i think that's exactly
what it is there you know they got a guy
like malcolm brown who's been around and
done that they'll be able to trust him
the salvin ahmed you know he did a good
job last year but you're right i don't
think you're ever going to see them
stuck with a big money running back
there in miami it is the new england
approach wait this week we want to go
outside and run outside zone more all
right let's use our running back that's
good at doing that you know this week
we're going to run you know in between
the guards and and pull lyman all right
this this running back's better at doing
that you know this is going to be pass
game week yeah i would think that's kind
of the platooning they're going to do
there but i still think it's i mean it's
going to be an important part of their
team i have a hard time thinking flores
defensive coach
all the assets they've put in
to
you know it's it's
first round second round offensive
lineman
all over that that offensive line there
to where i would think they're going to
run the ball and it's going to be a
major part of how they play overall on a
week-to-week basis
and you know when you look beyond the
the running backs the receivers
they got some impressive talent yeah you
got to keep them healthy they added will
fuller who's still got to do the back
end of a ped suspension and then stay
healthy after that devonta parker has
been a guy who's been up and down but
lately it feels like more up than down
jalen waddle they pounced on him with
the sixth overall pick in the draft
they've got jakeem grant lynn bowden
albert wilson who had his moments in
kansas city that's right mike gaseki and
durham smythe hunter long or rookie at
tight end they they got some decent
targets for tuatango by lower it's not
quite the daniel jones no excuses crew
but it's a pretty good group yeah agreed
that you're right that's the best way to
put it it's not like no excuses but you
can't look at it anymore and go oh man
they they need help but there's there's
issues here you know you're right i mean
devonte parker it's it's two years in a
row a very high level play you just got
to stay healthy all the way like you're
talking about preston williams is
another guy that you know pops for them
when he's healthy and does things gaseki
you mentioned him he's really talented
you know so yeah there is weapons hey
matt collins isn't a bad back end guy
there's plenty of depth here i mean i
think when you just take preston
williams devonte parker jalen waddle
that's a pretty impressive three and
then when william fuller gets back in
the mold or the you know in the in the
in the rotation there
whoa i mean that's four guys where you
got two guys with great size two other
guys who can really fly and put pressure
on the defense vertically and all those
type of things i think it's you know not
a top five group but i think it's top
half of the league as far as that's
concerned for sure
yeah it's it's definitely a group of
receivers
that that will give tuatanga viloa
opportunities to become the guy that
they thought he was going to be when
they made him the fifth overall pick in
the draft the offensive line is a key
component to whatever they're going to
do run the ball past the ball as it
always is and the better they are the
more they're overlooked unless they're
dominant but for just a good offensive
line you never even pay attention
because
you're paying attention to the guys
running the football and catching the
passes where do you put their group
in relation to everyone else well it's
it's like a potential group i think the
way is you know i look at it right now
as far as got like
young
budding talent to where you kind of saw
it coming together
at the end of last year
and
you know that's where you just look at
it and go wow i mean this is a pretty
damn good group across the line there
get a mat skura in there to to be a
little veteran leader at the center
position coming from baltimore but i
think everything else i mean
wow what's what's not to say or like
about it and really like jesse davis was
a guy that we don't have on that graphic
there because they drafted liam
eichenberg in the second round jesse
davis was really good for them last year
i would think he's going to start and
leah mikenberg is going to be at the guy
that's going to have to earn his way
there so their offensive line like again
another one maybe like the receivers
mike where you just go
you know it's not top five in football
but it's very talented and top half
and maybe at the end of this year with
those young guys and everything like
that it does get into the
borderline top five conversation it has
that type of potential and i think
that's why you you should be excited
about that group for sure
they get their chance right out of the
gates to show what they can do against
new england uh week one i think they
play the patriots week one and week
seven eighteen years start the season
right end the season that that that week
18 that's harder for me
than adjusting eight and eight to eight
and nine or nine and eight or six and 11
or whatever else adds up to 17. uh the
front seven defensively christian
wilkins rayquan davis emmanuel ogba
andrew van ginkel jerome baker bernard
mckinney
where where are they in your estimation
relative to the rest of the nfl
the front sevens it's got it all i mean
for me the only thing it was missing was
a pass rusher and they got the best pass
rusher in the draft in the fir in the
top 20 picks with jalen phillips they
killed it but there's like there's
nothing to look at to where you look at
their football team on the front seven
they got versatility they got size they
got speed they got everything as far as
that's concerned you know another good
defense and an emanuel agba who can do
everything you see him there hitting the
bangos quarterback but i think that
flores has this defensive roster just
where he wants it it's very new englandy
where oh wait we're playing a team this
week that likes to do three and four
receivers all right we got the secondary
to match up and all these linebackers we
can move them all around and do that oh
now this week we're playing the ravens
and we need to get big and stop the run
hey no problem we got christian wilkins
who we drafted in the first round a few
years ago and rayquan davis a second
round pick from la two years ago in
alabama where i go good luck moving
those two big suckers in the middle so
they got it all and then got a
bernardrik mckinney in a trade to be
their dante hightower thumping middle
linebacker that's where i keep coming
back to the phrase of like the dolphins
of like brilliant roster building
brilliant vision for the team with the
coach and the gm
of just coming together and
i mean it just to me it's
building a masterpiece down here as far
as the way the coach coaches and what he
wants to go along with it
yeah and it really does feel like a lot
of that new england dna right in the
division and the dolphins trying their
damnedest to compete with the patriots
and the bills and hold off the jets uh
while they're at it you mentioned the
secondary byron jones xavien howard
justin coleman eric rowe javon holland
and jason mccourty just signed recently
in free agents
um good enough on the back end
i mean special i think it's special when
you take you know byron jones
um you know xavier howard
their first round pick from two years
ago you know out of auburn uh oh i'm not
going to say his name because i'm going
to get scared to say it you know uh noah
uh iggy bainier i'm i'm i'm that's not
even close yeah i know it's not that's
not even close either way he did really
well you got them they drafted a javon
holland in the second round who for my
money was one of the two or three best
safeties in the draft i mean they again
it's just like the front seven they got
everything you want oh it's oh okay you
want to play four receivers oh we got
four dbs we can match you up play
man-to-man we can still blitz do all
these crazy things you know oh we got
extra safeties because it's only two
receivers and maybe you got some
versatile tight ends you know there's
there's really not a weakness there that
i look at
that you know that pops out to you set i
think the cornerback position's as
strong as there is in football as far as
a team is concerned safety was one you
looked at a little bit but with the
drafting of holland and eric rowe back
there it's pretty damn group down there
pretty damn good group they got down
there in miami
your pronunciation of the name was so
bad it had it
what is it no igbongan
but it had the effect temporarily that
little red light and men in black where
it erases your brain like you erased
you erased the problem
from my mind and i had to regroup look
at this
sorry noah yeah sorry i didn't mean i
don't mean to be disrespectful when i do
that i need practice with names like
that sometimes and i think then i choke
on live tv uh so sorry
all right uh so overall i i'm fascinated
by what the dolphins can do we saw some
flashes too yeah i really wish i really
wish and brian flores said this last
year
i really wish they would go back to the
old uniforms that they are the one team
whose alternate uniforms
are so much better like it's night and
day difference between the alternate
uniforms and the regular uniforms and
flores wants the old uniforms and he's
made it clear that this is a stephen
ross decision steven if you're listening
and if you are god how did you get so
successful for watching us but if you're
listening go back to the old uniforms
that one stinks
it stinks the other one is awesome it uh
i i don't mind
this is the one you like right here with
the gray face
and all that i'm with you
i like that better the stripes the gray
face mask i mean that's that's special
that's you know zonka and bob greasy to
me i'm the logo it's the logo the logo
is great old-school dolphin embrace it
the dolphin wearing the helmet he's
ready to play you're right
right to play ball let's go that's when
they were winning super bowls is when
they were wearing that so i don't know
you're right i'd probably you know air
on going back to that as well but like
really mike
i mean you know we just talked about
their team and we kind of talked about
them in pretty glowing fashion there
like what do you what do you what do you
expect they have a tough first five
games and my computer is crapped out on
me and i can't pull up the schedule
right now but i know it's tough because
i remember there we go there it is look
at that kristen on the spot
but what are you feeling from this team
this year you thinking playoffs for sure
well we are going to learn a lot from
them the first five weeks of the season
you know they go to london week six
and they don't have a bar right after it
peter king explained in football morning
in america they didn't want a buy after
it they come back and they play the
falcons who are coming off of a buy post
their game in london the dolphins are
one of the teams that have that very
late week 14 bye but yeah we're gonna
find out a lot from them early now it
could be a thing where they kind of fall
off but then the schedule softens
jaguars falcons texans
jets
and maybe they make a run late but
hey that's not an easy schedule i i
think that that they're one of these
teams i'm going to be watching though to
bust through the playoffs because every
year there's turnover yep there's seven
spots now
and this is a team that almost made it
last year it all comes down to two of
though this is either going to be tua
steps up and becomes the guy they
thought he was going to be and matches
joe burrow and justin herbert or the
dolphins decide after this year let's
use some of that draft capital that we
continue
to build and let's go out and either
trade for deshawn watson
or maybe one of the other guys who ends
up being disgruntled but desean watson i
think continues to be at the top of the
list yeah and you still can't think
about this
how would you feel about the dolphins
if
you found out
by the fourth of july that they were
trading for desean watson oh i mean it's
to me then it's like well they could be
a super bowl contender you know it i
don't want to say it's like it's it's a
super bowl contender but i almost feel a
little bit like
brady in the bucks a little bit like
whoa the team's talented can they just
come together
you know in time and get it all together
in time
to not lose too many games and still get
in the playoffs right that's kind of how
i would feel i really would but i would
go oh my gosh watch out for the future
because i do think miami is building
something special and i think you're
right with the tua thing i i don't ever
like to put it all on the quarterback
but where i just put it on to here to
you to your point is you know they won
so many games last year
in a way where they had to manage the
quarterback and manage the game
perfectly the defense had to play great
the special teams had to play great
flores had those great blitzes he had
for a while there remember when they
went through that stretch of like sean
mcvay and the rams and everybody was
flustered by some of the things they
were doing it's just too hard to win
like that on a week-to-week basis in the
nfl and that's where the quarterback can
take pressure off of all of that to
where okay not everything has to be
exactly perfect every week and if tua
can do that
then i say whoa watch out and miami will
be for real and in the playoffs
and and remember if they would get
deshaun watson whoever gets him he's
looking at a suspension even if all the
cases get resolved the criminal
investigation ends he's still looking at
something and people around the league
are thinking four to six games so they'd
have to get through that
tough stretch to start the season
without him and who knows when they
would even work him into the mix in 2021
if they end up trading for him but
whether it's this year or next year they
continue to be on that short list of
teams that may end up with them and that
would change everything in miami if it
would happen all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports